-Hello, everyone,
and welcome back
to the attic crawl space.
We have been focussing a lot
on the tiny door back there,
as well as the various
miniseries books
mysteriously appearing
over here on the side table.
And I just wanna say
I am really hoping a copy
of the "John Adams" biography
that inspired
the "John Adams" miniseries,
starring Paul Giamatti,
will show up,
but, with an infestation
of miniseries books like this,
you don't get
to choose the titles.
They just show up.
Anyway, speaking
of presidents --
classic segue --
President Trump seems intent
on opening the economy
by the end of the month,
even though he doesn't have
the power to do that
and public health experts
have warned against it.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
Since before Trump
was even considered
a serious candidate
for president,
it's always been clear that
he's worshipped authoritarians
and sought to emulate them.
For one thing,
those are the world leaders
he gets along with best.
For example, he's repeatedly
heaped praise
on Chinese President Xi Jinping,
including during the
coronavirus outbreak.
Trump tweeted...
Trump wants us
to forget all that now
because he thinks our brains
are like his, but they're not.
Most of us can form
and retain memories,
while Trump has the memory
of a goldfish who smokes weed.
"Hey, man, has that --
has that treasure chest
always been there?"
And, by the way,
I know it's hard
to remember back further
than a day,
since every day is a year
and every year is a month
and every month is
February-March-Augus-tember,
but Trump has claimed many times
that Article 2
of the Constitution,
which outlines the powers
of the presidency,
allows him to do literally
whatever he wants,
even though
it obviously does not.
-Then I have an Article 2,
where I have the right to do
whatever I want,
as president, but,
I don't even talk about that.
-"I have an Article 2"
is how a cabbie from Queens
would say it
will fighting
with a traffic cop.
[ changes accent ]
C'mon, you can't give me
a ticket for parking here!
I got an Article 2 that tells me
I can do whatever I want!
Some people were still
holding out hope
that, when [bleep] got serious,
Trump would get serious,
when, in reality, it was clear
he would just be [bleep]
And sure enough,
as recently as Monday,
he was insisting, once again,
that, as president,
he had absolute power
and could unilaterally order
every state in the country
to lift their
stay-at-home orders
and reopen their economies
as early as May 1st.
What authority you do have?
-Well, I have
the ultimate authority.
I have the absolute right
to do it, if I want to.
When somebody's the president
of the United States,
the authority is total
and that's way it's gotta be.
The president
of the United States
has the authority to do
what the president
has the authority to do,
which is very powerful.
-Talk about a meaningless
statement --
"The president
of the United States
has the authority to do
what the president
has the authority to do."
It's kind of the perfect
zero-information sentence.
It's like sayin'...
[ As Trump ] Hey!
I gotta be me!
Yeah, okay,
but who are you, though,
the wannabe dictator who's
best friends with Kim Jong-un
or the cherubic mascot for
Love Handles Golf Resort & Spa?
Seriously,
if the Continental Congress
had actually written that
down on parchment,
Ben Franklin would've charged
in the room and been like,
"Guys, guy-uy-s,
c'mon, what the hell is this?
Were you drunk last night?"
And George Washington
would've been like,
"Sorry, boss.
We drank too much applejack."
But John Adams
would've been like,
"I was busy defending
the soldiers
in the Boston Massacre."
See?
[ Singsong ] You guys!
I did watch the miniseries.
By the way, here's my impression
of Paul Giamatti
in "John Adams."
[ Grumbling ]
Abigail.
For real,
such a good miniseries.
Giamatti was so good.
So good, Lin Manuel left
John Adams out of Hamilton."
Is my theory.
And can we just agree now
that there should never,
ever, be
a Donald Trump miniseries,
or at least wait as long
as HBO did
after his term ended
to make "John Adams"?
Just don't make an actor
of Paul Giamatti's caliber
ever say the line
"The president
of the United States
has the authority to do
what the president
has the authority to do."
Because that's
an actual sentence
that came out of Trump's mouth.
I mean, can you imagine
if President Obama
had said something like that?
First of all, you can't,
because Obama was a smart person
who knew more than five words.
I mean, you never tuned
into a press conference
and saw a chyron that said...
Second, Fox News would've gone
into full meltdown mode.
Sean Hannity
would've screamed so loud,
the glass of your TV
woulda cracked.
Sorry, your grandfather's TV.
In fact, on his show, this week,
Hannity insisted states
could actually reopen sooner
than the end of the month.
-I think most states can reopen
even sooner than later.
We don't have to wait
'til may 1st.
-Okay, Sean.
You go first.
Take your show outside
and host it in Times Square
with Buzz Lightyear and Elmo.
Ask people to cough on you.
You can call it
"Cough-ee [coffee] Talk."
And then,
after significant pushback,
President Werewolf
seemingly changed course
and claimed that he would be
consulting with governors
on when to open their economies
and would authorize them
to implement their own plans
to do that.
-I will then be authorizing
each individual governor
of each individual state
to implement a reopening,
and a very powerful
reopening plan,
of their state,
at a time and in a manner
as most appropriate.
-You can't authorize people
to do something
they already have
the authority to do.
He's like a boss who thinks
he's being generous
by telling his employees, "Hey,
when your shift ends tonight,
feel free to, you know,
go home to your families,
or whatever.
I give you the permission
to do that."
Governors across the country,
and the political spectrum,
from California Governor
Gavin Newsom, a Democrat;
to Ohio Governor Mike DeWine,
a Republican;
have been skeptical
that the country
can just magically reopen
by the end of the month
without mass testing
and contact tracing
to track the spread
and isolate cases and, yet,
in his daily
Rose Garden campaign rally
on Wednesday night,
Trump insisted
that governors
are actually excited
to just open back up
as soon as possible.
-We'll also be speaking
to America's governors tomorrow
and then, we'll be announcing
exactly what's happening.
You already know
we'll be opening up states,
some states,
much sooner than others,
and we think some of the states
can actually open up
before the deadline of May 1st.
And I think that that will be
a very exciting time, indeed.
Governors are looking forward.
They're chomping at the bit
to get going.
-Nobody's chomping
at the bit, just yet.
I'm still wipin' down
every piece of mail
like the return address
says Chernobyl.
What do you even mean
by "opening up," anyway?
You can't make people go out.
You gonna have federal agents
knock on people's doors
and force them to go
to the Olive Garden?
"That's right, pass
the breadsticks around.
Everybody touch the basket.
Everybody
touch the basket!
You just can't make people go
to restaurants or stores
because you want them to.
In fact, a new poll,
published by Politico this week,
found that...
When it comes
to reopening the economy,
voters want the government
to move slowly,
not more quickly.
And that should be good
because moving slowly
is the one thing
Trump is good at,
both metaphorically
and literally.
He lumbers around the
White House lawn
like a retiree
spraying crabgrass.
[ As Trump ]
Do we are have any weed killer?
Just give me some Trump vodka.
It's the same thing.
In fact, that was
the ad campaign...
Public health experts
are warning us
that prematurely
reopening things
could have deadly consequences,
just like waiting to act
until it was too late
had deadly consequences,
and, yet, Trump is incapable
of absorbing that reality.
Just take this truly
chilling anecdote
from The Washington Post...
Dr. Anthony...
[ As Trump ]
Hmm, okay.
And, looking at your faces,
I'm guessing that's...
bad, that's a bad thing?
I mean, think about that.
Fauci actually had
to explain that
to the president.
No wonder he covers his face
during press briefings.
Soon, he's gonna start dressing
to blend into the
background completely.
[ As Trump ] Fauci!
I know you're here, Fauci.
I can hear you sighing.
I'm not gonna hurt you, Fauci.
I just wanna talk to you.
Trump seems intent on repeating
all the same mistakes he made
at the start of this crisis.
For example,
Trump has repeatedly bragged
about his China travel ban,
even though The New York Times
reported that...
And that, according
to a genetic study...
And that would probably come
as a shock to Trump,
who tweeted in 2014
about the Ebola outbreak...
You know how people always say,
"If you could travel back
in time, where would you go?"
And some people say ancient Rome
of the Wild West.
I'd go back six years
and introduce 2014 Donald Trump
to current Donald Trump,
just so he could see how much
of a hypocrite he is.
Of course, I understand.
It immediately backfire.
Before you send that tweet,
I think you should know that,
in six years from now,
you will be doing something
very similar, as president.
[ As Trump ] Holy [bleep]
I'm gonna be president?
Yes, but that's not the point
I was trying to make.
[ As Trump ] President of the
United States? What happened?
Look, no,
I have brought you here
to prove you're a hypocrite.
[ As Trump ] Well,
I think you mean President...
Hypocrite.
So, now, Trump and his allies
are trying to shift blame
for their inaction to China
and the
World Health Organization.
Now, of course, the World Health
Organization has its flaws,
but Trump is the one
who repeatedly praised China
for the handling of coronavirus,
and a global pandemic
is a worst time
to suddenly pull funding
from the world's leading
public health group.
And, when you hear the Trump
team's reasons, you realize
they are just incredibly stupid.
-But with the
World Health Organization,
what's happened there
is a disgrace.
There's something going on.
There's something
going on that's very bad.
It's been going on
for a long period of time
and we don't wanna be
the suckers anymore.
-This is COVID-19,
not COVID-1, folks,
and so would think the people
charged with the
World Health Organization
facts and figures
-Right.
-would be on top of that.
-Oh, my God,
you absurd Lady Beavis.
COVID-19 is named after the year
it was discovered, 2019.
There weren't 18 COVIDs
before this one.
You're confusing it with the
"Fast & Furious" movies.
Does she think there's a spinoff
called "Hobbs & SARS"?
Although, it would explain why,
when it comes to putting people
in charge of the government,
Trump's motto is...
-I don't have friends.
I got family.
-Okay.
I take it back.
You can do
a Trump miniseries now,
only if Vin Diesel plays him.
[ As Diesel ] The president
of the United States
has the authority to do
what the president
has the authority to do.
And all of this just reveals
the rot of bad faith
at the core of the modern GOP.
Conservatives
never really meant
any of that stuff
about limited government.
As we're seeing now, in fact,
Trump himself conveniently
changes his mind
whenever it suits him
and the whole GOP
turns in unison with him
like school of herring.
When he wanted to claim
absolute power,
he insisted that the president
calls the shots.
But when he was asked
about the failures
at the federal level
to ramp up testing
or when governors
were begging him
for life-saving equipment,
like ventilators
and protective gear,
he said he didn't
take responsibility
and actually bragged
that he wouldn't even call
the governors,
unless they praised him.
-Dr. Fauci said,
earlier this week,
that the lag in testing was,
in fact, a failing.
Do you take responsibility
for that
and when can you guarantee
that every single American
who needs a test
will be able to have a test?
What's the date of that?
-Yeah. No, I don't take
responsibility at all.
He calls all the governors.
I tell him. I mean,
I'm a different type of person.
I say, "Mike, don't call
the governor of Washington.
You're wasting your time
with him.
Don't call the woman
in Michigan."
-Okay, first of all,
she has a name --
it's Gretchen Whitmer --
and she's a governor.
On top from being
a sexist [bleep]
Trump's brain is so deteriorated
that he talks about governors
the way your dad talks
about an actress
he recognizes, but can't name.
"Who's the one who was
in the movie...
with the guy --"
Diane Lane, Dad.
It's always Diane Lane.
Look, we can't just open
the economy up by May 1st.
Not only does Trump not have
the power to do that,
but public health experts
are warning
that we won't be able
to just go back to normal
until there's mass testing;
contact tracing;
and, eventually, a vaccine.
A responsible president
would be preparing the nation
for that reality.
Instead, Trump is, once again,
trying to wave away the crisis.
As polls show,
people just don't believe him
and that's because...
-We don't wanna be
the suckers anymore.
-This has been "A Closer Look"
and this, one more time,
is my Paul Giamatti impression
from "John Adams."
[ Grumbling ]
Abigail, I am
vexed.
♪♪
City Harvest is New York City's
largest food rescue organization
and, now, they're working hard
to support local families
who are out of work due
to the COVID-19 pandemic.
If you're watching this online,
please hit the donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
We love you.